I want you to just think about this for
me this idea if you fill out a bunch of
numbers and you don't know what their
values are equal to but you know what
that sign is equal to can you know
something about the sign of when you
multiply or divide them together all
point out all these multiplication signs
could just as easily be division because
if you have a positive number it's
reciprocal will also be positive right
so therefore for example multiplied by a
positive ends up being the same in terms
of the effect on the sign as dividing by
a positive right you still don't change
the sign it to go to quite a number and
you still will change the sign if you
have a negative number regardless of
which operation you're doing okay so
actually if you have a pair of buddies
numbers like say 1 or 2 and you multiply
them what will happen to the size the
product it will also be positive if on
the other hand you've got a positive and
a negative number regardless of how big
or slow they are if you know their sign
then the sign of the product will be
negative and you could have keep going
to this right it's it's not complicated
if you have two negatives than a quad
burger which you can't believe you with
a northerner okay and this principle
continues as the number of factors
increases right so trick positive is
still very positive to positive and
negative so you get the idea
okay and of course you could extend this
to four or five factors which we are
going to look at as we graph so here's
the idea this is how numbers behave when
you have a look at a function like this
each of the factors of this function
behaves just like it number like X minus
2 is another it's just a number that can
change that's how we call X and variable
right so therefore one of them asked us
to do is treat each of these as a line a
graph on our
active so you've got s you've got X
minus two and you've got X plus 2 these
are the factors of y equals x or the X
minus 2 X plus 2 so each one of them
independently I can grab now I have the
super advantage of having lots of fun
colors here that I have access to if you
have lots of colors then go ahead and do
it what I'm doing now but in all you
have is a petal then what you're about
to draw out that's during orange maybe
just do it sort of lightly because you
don't want it to get from where y equals
x 1 equals X minus 2 and y equals x plus
2 in just straight line they look like
this
well done is each of these and I'm not
even in a level is because they're not
even part of my actual grand they're
just lines it will help me do the real
round each of these is a factor right
each one is going to divide up the graph
into sections okay so I'm going to
notice from the left of negative 2 to
the right big into this factor here
which is why would that trust to it
change your side it goes from negative
to positive do you notice that so
therefore on the left of something like
that one thing is happening and then to
the right of it something else to cover
you the safety habit of 0 to the left
and then to the right you have a change
inside and then lastly 4x minus 2 2 is
the battery point to the left and to the
right you have a change inside so I'm
going to draw another one here so now
I'm going to get a highlighter out let's
do a repeat remember we said before to
our negatives and a negative and ages
whether you multiply or divide them
together you're going to get a negative
now have a look over here even though it
doesn't quite explain that far over to
the left here both side thing is to of
this side all three factors are big if
you notice that I don't know what this
sign is up but I don't need to know this
size I just need this sign three
negatives will give you a negative
positive side of the mountain
okay maybe you want to shade this and
like put your pencil sideways or
something like that so you could shade
in this region Pervez p.m. let's pick
something at its finest shall we now you
can see when you transition from the
left of negative two to the right you
now going to have three negative factors
have a look at the signs you've got two
positive and two negative sounds here
right so when you multiply and divide
them what we be able resolve we positive
and in fact what you can see is it just
switches up and down each time it
crosses each time it changes sign so you
can see I've got this guy over here and
in this guy over here okay that one that
I did first is bothering me because it's
so messy so I'm just going to fix it
there we go that's a little bit better
right question we have a parabola in the
middle and that's when it's done change
what is that look like yeah I'll get to
that
I promise I'll show you this [ __ ] with
your mouth area and up ahead you're
feeling okay
alright now I rub the regions through
which this area goes through okay and
there are also going to be some
asymptotes on this function
something asymptotes that you need to
see in fact I've sort of problems
already there are two vertical
asymptotes where are they x equals
negative two and actually profunda - so
I'm going to quickly be solidly now to
indicate yep I see what's happening here
X is negative 2 and X is positive 2 like
so there's also a horizontal asymptote
can you help me work out what the
horizontal asymptote is 0 it's going to
eat now we're going to keep pursuing
this right it's blood 0 it's y equal 0
right assets which aligns what topic
number drives our equations right and I
know you said or two and they give two
but those are vertical isotope so
they're x equals negative 2 at x equals
positive
so the horizontal asymptote is y equals
zero
how do you know that limits if you think
about limits right the horizontal
asymptote comes from would be just
finished drawing all the way across it
comes from the behavior of your fashion
this guy our PR and X approaches
infinity all the way to the right and
it's approaches negative 50 all the way
to the left
yeah and you can quickly cut your
numbers easy and you're like oh that's a
nominate up get massive right so
therefore you're going to get a very
smaller
okay what you want to do on any graph
the intercepts are usually pretty poor
things right so we find the x-intercepts
it'll sort of wonder I don't know in
this case when you put in X equal 0
because X is in the denominator
sorry giver it up you just get y equal 0
right so in fact it passes through the
origin right there in the middle which
is we the first cuz you're like wait
I've been acting so but you can pass
through this horrible glasses are like
that because the horizontal asymptotes
about the limit limit over here as if
it's over there have nothing to do with
the center of the graph so now I have
everything ID I've got the regions that
are the pasture I've got the asymptotes
I'm supposed to approach at the right
spots and I also have an intercept so
I'm just going to go from left to right
and draw it how it has to be have a look
at this vector here what do you think is
happening
yeah you just you know you just sort of
want it in this area right you've got to
do something that look like that it
looks like one branch of a hyperbola
doesn't it okay
I've in or else you can go you can't
possibly be positive because we already
shaded that region and you've got to get
towards these episodes so that gives you
the rest of the shape there's nothing
that can like curl around or something
like that don't do that students often
when they during this they're kind of
like oh let it come a little bit don't
let it kill a little bit get your rubber
out fix that be that's not even a
function anymore that's a this doesn't
pass the vertical line test it collides
twice so that would be a relation right
that's not the shape that you want this
isn't this is the shape that you want
and as long as you're approaching point
while we look at that kind of shape you
notice the same company is happening to
the top right but but reversed right so
you look down in that top area and you
rember two asymptotes so that's where
you've got a kind of similar shape like
that okay last one is the middle now one
thing is the middle you've got an asset
over your left you're going to acetone
overview of the Ryan and you know you're
going to pass right through the origin
so therefore you can always change the
our country it looks a little bit like a
tear draft doesn't it it's a little bit
like tango and then the fact that
probably causes comparison I would say
and there you go there's the graph so
that